the height of a triangle is four inches
less than the length of the base the
area of the triangle is 30 inches
squared find the height and base use the
formula area equals one-half base times
height
for the area of a triangle okay so let's
think about it a little bit we have the
bit let me draw a triangle here so this
is our triangle and let's say that the
length of this bottom side that's the
base let's call that B and then this is
the height this is the height right over
here and then the area is equal to 1/2
base times side area is equal to 1/2
base times height now in this first
sentence they tell us that the height of
the height of a triangle is 4 inches
less than the length of the base so the
height is equal to the base minus 4
that's what that first sentence tells us
the area of the triangle is 30 inches
squared so if we take 1/2 the base times
the height we'll get 30 inches squared
or we could say we could say that 30
inches squared is equal to 1/2 times the
base times the base times the height now
instead of putting an H in for height we
know that the height is the same thing
as 4 less than the base so let's put
that in there for less than the base and
then let's see what we get here we get
let me do this in yellow we get 30 is
equal to 1/2 times let's distribute this
B times B let me make it clear
actually let's let's do it this way
times B over 2 times B minus 4 I just
multiplied the 1/2 times the B now let's
distribute the B over 2 so 30 is equal
to B squared over over 2 be careful B
over 2 times B is just B squared over 2
and then B over 2 times negative 4 is
negative 2b now just to get rid of this
fraction here let's multiply both sides
of this equation by 2 so let's multiply
that side by 2 and let's
multiply that side by two on the
left-hand side you get 60 on the
right-hand side two times B squared over
two is just B squared negative 2 B times
2 is negative 4 B and now we have a
quadratic here and the best way to solve
a quadratic we have a second degree term
right here is to get all of our all of
the terms on one side of the equation
having them equal 0 so let's subtract 60
from both sides of this equation let's
subtract 60 from both sides and we get 0
is equal to B squared minus 4 B minus 60
and so what we need to do here is just
factor this thing right now or factor it
and then know that if I have the product
of some things and that equals 0 that
means that either one or both of those
things need to be equal to 0 so we need
to factor B squared minus 4 B minus 60
so what we want to do we want to find
two numbers whose sum is negative 4
whose sum is negative 4 and whose
product is negative 60 so we want to
find two numbers whose sum is equal to
negative 4 and whose product is equal to
negative 60 now given that their product
is negative we know there are different
signs and this tells us that they're
their absolute values are going to be 4
apart that one is going to be 4 less
than the other so you can look at the
products of the factors of 60 1 and 60
are too far apart even if you made one
of them negative you would either get
positive 59 as a sum or negative 59 as a
sum 2 and 30 is still too far apart 3
and 15 3 and 20 sorry it's still too far
apart if you have made one negative you
would either get negative 17 or positive
17 then you can have 4 and 15 still too
far apart if you made one of them
negative their sum would be either
negative 11 or positive 11 then you have
5 and 12 still seems too far apart from
each other
one of them is negative then you would
either have there's some being positive
7 or negative 7 then you have 6
and ten now this looks interesting
therefore apart so if we make and we
want the larger absolute magnitude
number to be negative so that their sum
is negative so if we make it six and
negative 10 their sum will be negative 4
and their product is negative 60 so that
works so you can literally say that this
is equal to this is equal to B plus 6
times B minus 10 B plus 2 a times B
minus or plus B minus the B and now let
me be very careful here
this B over here I want to make it very
clear is different is different than the
B that we're using in the equation I
just use this B here to say look we're
looking for two numbers that add up to
this second term right over here it's a
different B I could have said X plus y
is equal to negative 4 and x times y is
equal to negative 60 in fact let me do
it that way just so we don't get
confused so we could write x plus y is
equal to negative 4 and then we have x
times y is equal to negative 60 so we
have B plus 6 times B plus y X is 6 Y is
negative 10 and that is equal to 0 and
you could you could well let's just
solve this right here and then we'll go
back and show you that you could also
factor this by grouping but just from
this we know that either one of these is
equal to 0 either B plus 6 is equal to 0
or B minus 10 or B minus 10 is equal to
0 if we subtract 6 from both sides of
this equation we get B is equal to
negative 6 or if you add 10 to both
sides of this equation you get B is
equal to 10 and those are our two
solutions you could put them back in and
verify that they satisfy our constraints
now the other way that you could solve
this and we're going to get the exact
same answer is you can just break up
this negative 4b into its constituents
so you could have broken this up into 0
is equal to B squared and then you could
broken it up into +6 B minus 10 B plus 6
B minus 10 B minus 60 and then factor it
by grouping group these first two terms
group these second two terms just going
to add them together the first one you
can factor out a B so you have B times B
plus 6 the second one you can factor out
a negative 10 so minus 10 times B plus 6
all that's equal to 0 and now you can
factor out a B plus 6 so if you factor
out a B plus 6 here then you get 0 is
equal to B minus 10 times B plus 6 we're
literally just factoring out we're
literally just factoring out this out of
the expression you're just left with the
B minus 10 B minus 10 you get the same
thing that we did in one step over here
whatever works for you but either way
the solutions are either B is equal to
negative 6 or B is equal to 10 and we
have to be careful here remember this is
a word problem we can't just stay Toby
could be negative 6 or B could be 10 we
have to we have to think about whether
this makes sense in the context of the
actual problem we're talking about
lengths of triangles or lengths of the
sides of triangles we can't have a
negative length we can't have a negative
length so because of that we can't the
base of a triangle can't have lengths
negative 6 so we can cross that out so
we actually only have one solution here
almost made a careless mistake forgot
that we were dealing with a word problem
the only possible base is 10 and let's
see they say find the height and the
base once again not done so the base
we're saying is 10 the height is 4
inches less it's B minus 4 so the height
is 6 and then you can verify the area is
6 times 10 times 1/2 which is 30